today on the matt walsh show uh many
people claim that we should not be
legislating morality or
forcing our morality on others i
disagree i think that's exactly what we
should do and i'll explain why today
and our five headlines jeff bezos
launches himself into space the academy
of the american academy of pediatrics
calls for children to wear masks as the
new school year starts
as we remain stuck in this never-ending
time warp and also new and damning
revelations about the state
representative of minnesota who claims
he was racially profiled
during a traffic stop and npr puts out a
hit hit piece on the daily wire and in
our daily cancellation
we'll discuss a viral video which shows
that some americans
literally don't know what century
they're currently living in
all of that and much more today on the
matt wall show
well we celebrated our freedom as a
country earlier
uh this this month at least some of us
did those of us who actually love
america
celebrated it and you know nothing
says freedom like growing a thick
manly beard it is a god-given
right that we all have it is right there
in the constitution somewhere
we all have the inherent right to grow
beards um
and does that mean that if you're not
growing a beard you're an un-american
communist
i'm not gonna go that far but yeah so
that's exactly what it means if you're
one of these manly men that are
currently growing or already have a
manly beard chances are you're in need
of products to keep it looking thick and
healthy
if so you need to go visit
beardsupply.com because for a limited
time
only you can buy one beard oil product
and get another one free
you do need to keep to have the upkeep
like i don't i don't care about any
other part of my appearance
except the beard it's the one thing i
care about and that's why you need beard
supplies it's a great deal
uh already affordable top quality
products and now you get the extra deal
on top of it
you cannot find this kind of deal
anywhere else so go to beardsupply.com
today and order yourself two beard oils
for the price of one you can mix and
match
different scents or stock up on an old
classic like their best seller winter
number one
for a limited time only again that's
beardsupply.com and buy one beard oil
and get another one for free
now we discussed yesterday the story of
the self-proclaimed conservative porn
star quote unquote who has
found many defenders on the right after
she was kicked out of a conference for
conservative high school students
today it's apparently consistent with
our values to have hardcore porn stars
at events for teenagers
in a few years no doubt these same
conservatives will be
insisting that just because someone is a
in a cannibal sex cult that shouldn't
preclude them from becoming a youth
pastor
dems are the real cannibal phobes but
i've already said all that needs to be
said on that topic and probably
more than needs to be said about it as
is my custom
instead i'd like to focus in on and
analyze a claim that's been made in
relation to this subject and
has also been made of course countless
times before
the claim that you're familiar with is
that we should not be trying to enforce
our morality or legislate our morality
or
impose our morality instead we should be
advocates for freedom
we should simply leave people alone and
let them live as they choose
you've heard this i'm sure over and over
again maybe you've said it yourself over
and over again
never mind that this really has nothing
to do with the porn star the student
conference thing
uh it doesn't but that's fine it's an
interesting discussion nonetheless
and it's important because it brings us
back to some very fundamental questions
so should we want to
enforce our morality or or even
legislate our morality
thereby imposing it on other people who
may or may not agree with it
the answer is emphatically yes we should
definitely so here's a basic concept
and we can't get anywhere really until
we've grasped it
all laws are based in morality
every piece of legislation ever written
anywhere on earth for all of time has
legislated morality
every law everywhere always
represents an imposition of morality
everyone who lives in a country governed
by laws
lives therefore in a country where
morality is being forced on them
there are no exceptions to this you
cannot escape it
laws against murder everyone agrees with
those
except if it's murder inside the womb um
but laws against murder are based on the
belief that murder is evil
if murder was not evil then it shouldn't
be illegal
if murder was good then we should be
allowed to do it nothing that is truly
good should be illegal that doesn't mean
that all evil things
should be illegal necessarily but it
does mean that only what is evil
should be illegal and all that is good
should be legal
everyone basically agrees with this
intuitively until it's pointed out
so what i just said there everyone
that's how everyone operates you just
assume that
until someone says it out loud and then
for some reason many people become
disturbed
by the belief that they themselves have
always held without fully realizing it
this applies with the really important
laws the big laws like the laws against
murder
goes all the way down to traffic laws
the law requiring you to wear a seat
belt is grounded in the idea that seat
belts protect people from harm
and it's morally good to protect people
from harm
every law either forbids people from
doing something
or requires them to do something i can't
really think of
any law that doesn't do in effect one of
those things
why are we forbidding people from doing
that thing whatever it is well because
that thing is bad
or so the government claims why are we
requiring them to do something well
because that thing is good
or so the government claims obviously
the moral code that informs any given
law can be wrong
horribly wrong in some cases but there
must be
some kind of moral code if you dig to
the bottom of any law
and you find that there is no moral code
or moral claim in forming it
then that law should be by def then that
law by definition would be arbitrary
which would make it tyrannical and it
shouldn't exist
i mean what would an amoral or non-moral
law even be
how would it be justified
what would that look like what would it
sound like a legislator would say i'm
introducing a bill to make it illegal to
wear a red shirt on tuesdays between
three and four o'clock
and the public would say it would ask
why why why that law
is it harmful is it bad to wear a red
shirt during that time where is this
coming from
uh no no it isn't bad but but still it
should be illegal
at least i'm not legislating morality
even the people who say they don't want
the government to legislate morality
would have a problem with a law like
that precisely because
it doesn't legislate morality
whenever a law is proposed the first
thing everyone wants to know
is whether that law has a moral basis
that's like the only thing anyone cares
about with any law
that's what every argument about every
law is really about
if a law doesn't have a moral basis or
if the moral argument for it is not
persuasive then we oppose the law
this is how everyone operates even as
most of us claim that we don't want any
laws to be based on morality
and that's because we're very confused
and we haven't taken even 15 seconds to
figure out what we actually believe and
why we believe it
now the way people try to get around
this is by saying well i don't want laws
that
are moral or religious i just want the
law to protect my rights that's all i
want
people should be able to do whatever
they want as long as they aren't hurting
me
or taking my rights away there are a
number of serious problems with that
logic starting with the fact that the
whole idea of
your rights is a religious idea from the
start
i hate to tell you it is uh well i don't
hate to tell you but you might hate to
hear it
it is almost entirely based on the
belief
human rights i mean entirely based on
the belief
that we are created by a supernatural
power and imbued with these human rights
during that process
that's why that's what it says in the
declaration of independence and that's
really the only basis for inherent human
rights that anyone has ever come up with
the doctrine of human rights is just
that it's a doctrine
human rights were not discovered by
science
they aren't a fact that can be seen you
can't open up someone's
body during an autopsy and say well
that's where the human rights are right
there
it doesn't work that way they don't
exist human rights in any physical
sense except written in the law but we
all believe or claim to believe
that the law doesn't invent the right so
much as protect what is already
inherently
though invisibly present if the
government invented rights if the
government decided who has rights and
who doesn't
then you'd never be able to claim that
the government is infringing on your
rights
because they're the ones who decide so
if you've ever claimed that the
government is infringing on your rights
then you are
claiming that human rights are this
inherent
invisible supernatural thing
which is a religious idea a spiritual
idea
if you believe in inherent human rights
you are religious
you are and aside from that
wherever these rights come from why
exactly shouldn't someone take them away
from you
why shouldn't someone harm you i don't
want
anyone to legislate morality i just i
just i just don't think you should be
hurting me
well why not why shouldn't i go up and
punch you right in the nose
why shouldn't i shoot you in the head
yeah because
it hurts i imagine you don't like it
it would make you sad and then you'd be
dead
okay but why should i give a damn about
that why does that matter
see eventually whether you like it or
not
you have to say that your rights should
be protected
and you should be preserved from
physical harm because it's evil to take
your rights away or cause you harm
whatever it is that you think should be
legally prohibited
your reason for holding that position is
that you think that thing or that act
is morally wrong
what is the point here is this just
semantics
no this this is as far from semantics as
it gets
what we're talking about is the nature
of law itself
i would call that anything but semantics
and we can't really have a coherent and
fruitful conversation about laws
unless we all understand what they are
and why they exist
that's why we don't have any fruitful
conversations or debates in this country
at all because
no one knows what they believe
we're using a lot of terms laws rights
equality
very few people have stopped to even
think about what they're saying or what
any of that
means or where it comes from
now once we do understand these things
once we've all acknowledged that laws
are moral
constructs by definition and we've
dispensed with this don't legislate
morality
silliness this childish garbage
then we can talk about the morals
themselves because just because all laws
have a moral basis that doesn't mean all
laws
are moral obviously not
the morals that the laws are rooted in
can be wrong sometimes horrifically
murderously murderously wrong going back
to abortion okay that
the people who argue for the laws that
uh
that uh protect abortion rights
they're making a moral argument for
those laws
saying it's wrong to infringe on a
woman's bodily autonomy so on and so
forth
it's just that the moral argument
they're making is bad and wrong
see our criticism of the law in the case
of abortion for example
is not that it has a moral basis it's
not that oh you're you're imposing
morals on me
it's that it has a bad moral basis
we want a law a system a country a
society
grounded in good morals correct morals
not bad morals
not to oversimplify but that's it
we certainly don't want a country
grounded in no morals at all
we're not nihilus even most nihilists
aren't really nihilus if they're really
nihilus they would have
they'd be dead by now from suicide
so this is what we have to get around to
especially as conservatives
and it's it's a simple concept we are
fighting for a moral society
moral laws moral government and that's a
good thing to fight for
it's nothing to be ashamed of we should
say it out loud
and then get to work now let's get to
our five headlines
you know the daily wire team in
nashville continues to grow much to
these to the chagrin as we'll talk about
of uh many people in the media and on
the left who are not happy about it but
we are and we currently have
multiple open positions across the
company all of which can be viewed
at dailywire.com careers this week we're
highlighting the
paid media buyer opening i have no idea
what that even
is but this member of the daily wire
marketing team oh it'll tell us we'll
create and execute
paid media campaigns for the daily wire
we're looking for someone who is
skilled with organization time
management and attention to detail at
least one year of previous professional
experience
and a paid media buyer or similar role
is required
and excel proficiency is crucial once
again there's another job that they
could have asked me to do
how do all these jobs just give them to
me even though i don't even know what
they are
i just want the extra money is all i'm
saying but they're not going to give it
to me they might give it to you
this is an in-office position in
nashville tennessee a qualified
candidate should apply through
dailywire.com
careers so jeff bezos launched himself
into space
today he's a second billionaire in a
week to do that richard branson was
before him
the internet has reacted to this and i
think he
launched this morning and i'm pretty
sure he came back down safely i never
did check
i assume if jeff bezos had exploded or
was drifting off to jupiter right now
probably would have seen that in the
news
so he launched his space came back down
safely and the internet has
reacted to the news as you'd expect lots
of people
complaining that bezos is rich there's a
lot of that
lots of people laughing because the
spaceship looks like a penis
um typical thoughtful type of analysis
that you that you anticipate
from social media and i'm okay with all
that you know the phallus jokes
the general jeff bezos hate fine i mean
the ship does look kind of like a penis
and that is sort of funny
and jeff bezos is pretty awful i'm
certainly not a jeff bezos apologist
or fan however what i can't abide are
the people acting like it's
insignificant
or boring that private individuals are
now launching themselves into space
it's a big deal and it does matter and
it's a good thing and it's also
impressive
as much as i don't like jeff bezos it is
impressive
that he started this company as garage
30 years ago
and now he's launching himself into
space with a rocket ship that he funded
with his own money
but i mean i'd call that impressive
we can acknowledge that can't we
um but beyond that beyond jeff bezos
himself
you know this is it's a good development
and it's it's exciting to be on the cusp
of this
as i explained last week yes right now
suborbital space
is a playground for billionaires that's
true that's what it is right now
but um many new advancements start that
way there was a time when a basic
blender
you know would have cost you the
equivalent of like 500 bucks
there was a time when only rich people
had cars or microwaves or tvs you know
and the list goes on
but that's at the beginning so we're at
the beginning of something and
and and with the government deciding
not to push out into space and explore
because that's the other thing i've
heard that oh
we went to the moon decades ago and now
he's just going to sub-orbital space
what's the big deal that's not
impressive
well i again i do think it's pretty
impressive to go to space at all it's
probably more impressive than anything
you've done
in your life um but
uh even even more than that
you know the fact that we went to the
moon and then just stopped going
well that's that's the government and so
now we have private individuals
private actors who are
pushing out innovating and sparking
perhaps what will be
a new age of discovery and innovation
how is that not exciting to you i don't
get it
be excited about this damn you
um and you here's here's the other thing
you need
yeah jeff bezos is uh is an a-hole but
you need rich a-holes to do stuff like
this
history shows us that that's what you
need
elon musk wants to send people to mars
is that is that insane to do that maybe
who would want to go to mars right now
even way in the future there's actually
some sort of colony built on mars who
would want to go live there
in this desolate wasteland where you got
to live in a bubble who would want to do
that
i mean i don't want to do it i'm not
signing up for it
it's kind of a crazy thing to do and you
could argue all you want that is a
massive waste of money
well you need if we want to push
new boundaries and explore and discover
and um expand our horizons in a very
little
literal sense then you need people with
lots of money
at their disposal who are willing to do
things that seem
insane and suicidal
that's been the case for explorers and
discoverers going back centuries and
centuries
and uh now you've got billionaires
stepping up to do it and i got to say
of all the things they could be spending
their money on i think this is one of
the best things they could be spending
their money on
i think it was jeff bezos also bought i
think he was the billionaire maybe it
was someone else another billionaire
who bought one of the recently bought
one of the biggest yachts in the world
with its own pri
with its own backup yacht that goes with
it its own support yacht
you get a billionaire spending money on
stuff like that
um which is nothing but pure vanity
and nothing more and vanity and luxury
this might be vanity too
but it could take us you know in in an
exciting direction
as a species and so i'm in favor of that
all right
this is from here's something that i'm
not in favor of this is from nbc it says
everyone older than age
two should wear masks regardless of
action vaccination status
when schools reopen in the fall
according to updated guidance
from the american academy of pediatrics
released on monday
the leading national pediatrician group
said it recommends universal masking
because so much of the student
population isn't yet eligible for
vaccination
it's not clear how quickly that will
change or how likely parents will be to
get their younger children dosed
when the federal government approves
shots for kids under 12.
let me be one parent to step up right
now and say even though i'm not getting
sending my kids to public school
uh my kids also certainly will not be
in line to get dosed whenever that
possibility opens up for them i will we
will be respectfully declining thank you
very much
oh you want to inject this drug into my
children's arm to protect them from an
illness that poses almost
no risk to that to them already tempting
but no thank you
it continues research consistently shows
opening schools in person doesn't
generally increase community covered
transmission when masks and other
protocols are employed
and the emergence of more contagious
variants some of which are linked to
more severe outcomes poses a particular
threat
to people who aren't vaccinated and
that's why we're going to
put the masks on kids over the age of
two so
three-year-olds in preschool are going
to be masked
forget about the studies that have shown
that that
this is doing more harm than good
because of all the bacteria and the
grossness that's accumulating in these
masks these kids are
breathing in all day
to protect them from a virus that once
again poses almost
no risk to them and that was the case
when this thing was raging out of
control and there was no vaccine
and uh and very little herd immunity at
all that was the case a year ago a year
and a half ago we knew that
there was no reason to shut the schools
down to put masks on kids
last year
and how much more is that the case now
when hundreds of millions of adults have
acquired immunity either from prior
effect infection or from
from the vaccine
there is no getting around this it it
it is just a fact that the flu
poses a greater threat to young kids
especially now
than kovit ever has that is a
statistical
fact so if we're putting masks on the
kids for covid
then they should just be wearing masks
all the time everywhere
never ending and if you and if you're
proposing if you support masking kids
now
you should have been you should have
been arguing for that five years ago 10
years ago you should have always been
arguing for that
no getting around this
and so the people who advocate masking
kids how do they get around it they
they simply ignore this reality you
can't get them to
acknowledge it
you you could you can try to beat this
into their
skulls as much as you metaphorically as
much as you as much as you want it
there's there is
it's just a there's a resistance there
they have their own immunity they're
immune from reason and logic
i've tried this so many times i'm sure
you have also whether talking to
somebody in person
or online and they say well we need we
need masks on kids it's still it's still
out there they're not vaccinated
yes but it poses almost no risk to them
the flu is a greater risk what don't you
understand about you grab them by the
color
why is this so difficult
and it's a blank stare
their brains have been so warped by the
by the panic porn being pushed on them
that they can't it it doesn't
sink in and it doesn't help when you got
guys like fauci who appeared on cnn
yesterday
uh saying that uh the american academy
pediatrics
telling us to muzzle our three-year-olds
he says it's a it's a reasonable thing
to do let's listen to fouchy
well i think that's along the same lines
as what we've seen with the health
authorities
in los angeles which in the general
population has said the same thing that
when you have
a degree of viral dynamics in the
community
and you have a substantial proportion
of the population that is unvaccinated
that you really want to go the extra
step the extra mile to make sure that
there's not a lot of transmission
even breakthrough infections among
vaccinated individuals and for that
reason
you can understand why the
uh the american academy of pediatrics
might want to do that they just want to
be extra
safe i think you know it's important the
cdc recommendations
may be at variance with that but in in
in every respect the cdc always
leads open the flexibility at the part
of local
agencies local enterprises local cities
and states
to make a judgment call based on the
situation on the ground
so i think that the american academy of
pediatrics you know they're a thoughtful
group
they analyze the situation and if they
feel that that's the way to go i think
that's reasonable thing to do
the pure pure cowardice from voucher you
could tell from his answer
i would almost prefer to hear him
uh i i would prefer not to hear him at
all let me be clear but
it would be not quite as bad but still
bad
if he was more aggressive about it and
said oh absolutely we need to have masks
on kids
you know this is this is what we need to
do and he was he was much more direct
and aggressive about it
but you can tell from his answer that he
knows that the kids don't need to wear
masks he knows that
he's just trying the best he can to
rationalize what the american
academy pediatrics is saying here
for no reason other than you know there
he thinks they're sort of on the same
team he's going to have their back
he doesn't care about the kids much less
about the truth but
the american academy pediatrics maybe
maybe they go to the same cocktail
parties the people there in him and he
doesn't want to upset them i don't know
what the
reasoning is but he knows that there's
no reason for this
it's thoughtful this is a thought
thoughtful and reasonable no it's not
it's it's it's the opposite of that this
is the opposite of thoughtful
because the precedent that you're
setting here what you're what you're
saying
is that there needs to be zero risk
of covid there needs to be zero covered
and zero risk before we can take the
masks off
because right now for kids especially at
the age group we're talking about
the threat is as close to zero as it can
get
can't get much closer without being zero
the threat especially of severe uh
reaction to covet for kids
close to zero
uh and if that's not good enough
then what you're saying is we need zero
risk
which means never take the mask off
because there's never gonna be zero risk
and even if there was even if we could
eradicate covet
completely it didn't exist anymore cover
19 is gone
which which isn't going to happen that
was never really in the cards
it's always going to be there it's going
to be around
probably more of a seasonal thing and
there's a vaccine for it
but even if we could eradicate it so now
there's zero risk of that
but there's no but there's there's not
zero risk of it
there are plenty of other things out
there where the risk is above zero
so is this the only risk we're worried
about and once that goes away
we could get we could get back to normal
if you're saying zero risk of covid why
just covet why not zero risk of anything
else
it doesn't make any logical sense it's
not thoughtful
in the slightest and this is why one of
the great casualties
not just of the pandemic but before that
and beyond it is that health authorities
so-called health authorities and the
entire medical industry
has completely lost both its scientific
credibility and its moral standing it
has lost its moral and scientific
credibility
again that's not only because of covid
these are the same people who tell us
that we should
you know start giving hormone pills and
uh gender affirmation surgeries to
minors
so they would lose their scientific
credibility and moral standing based on
that alone
but this is only speeding up that
process nobody cares what these people
have to say anymore
no one's listening except the most
deluded people
everyone else has tuned it out all right
uh
moving on an update to a story that
we've covered on the show you may recall
representative john thompson he's the
minnesota state representative who was
pulled over for a traffic violation and
then immediately claimed that he was
racially profiled
it was a lie of course he wasn't and
they released the body cam footage and
nothing inappropriate happened in the
body cam footage
he committed a violation they pulled him
over the cop was nice and respectful
even as thompson was was belligerent and
angry and accusing him of racism
but it also turned out that thompson had
a suspended license a suspended out of
state license
um if he doesn't he doesn't have a
license
and the license was suspended because he
wasn't paying childs for child support
payments so the guys are dead beat dead
big surprise there but but he doesn't
have a license in the state he
represents
in fact as it has developed over the
last week or so it's not clear that he's
a resident at
all of the state he represents much less
the district
and he's been asked about this there was
a video of someone who saw him at the
airport
and was saying you know representative
are you a resident of your own district
and he wouldn't answer the question
and now this from fox 9
uh in st paul it says in searching for
state representative john thompson's
residency
fox 9 has uncovered four cases of
domestic violence
with allegations that thompson punched
hit and choked women
according to the police reports from
2003-2009 in some cases the assaults
happen in the presence of young children
questions about thompson's residence he
were raised after he was stopped by
saint paul police on july 4th for not
having a front license plate
uh he accused them of uh of racial
profiling we know about that okay the
domestic violence cases stretch back to
2003
in superior wisconsin when thompson was
arrested after he allegedly struck his
girlfriend in the face with an open and
closed fist
the woman's five-year-old daughter
witnessed the assault which happened in
a supermarket parking lot
thompson's girlfriend said she and her
child were homeless and declined to
cooperate
thompson apparently fled the scene in
that case thompson allegedly attacked
the same girlfriend nearly a year later
on in august of 2004
at her apartments police arrived after a
9-1-1 hang-up call
she said that thompson choked her and
then
uh she said she ran out of the apartment
screaming but thompson grabbed her and
dragged her back to the apartment
she said she tried to escape through a
window she told police thompson became
angry when she dialed 911 from another
phone and began hitting her in the head
punching her in the face and then he
grabbed her and threw her into the
kitchen table
which broke all of her children
witnessed the assault
and then in september what else do we
have here in september 2009 st
paul police officers responded to a call
of domestic violence involving thompson
and two women
thompson and the women were fighting
about a cell phone he received from
another girlfriend that's unclear from
the report
if it's the girl from the previous case
uh during
that 2009 incident according to reports
as the yelling escalated thompson pulled
out his penis in front of his girlfriend
and two young children and said i'm the
man you can all
and then he had some sexually explicit
things to say um
and then he there was another case of
domestic violence as well so
this is someone allegedly involved in
allegedly
a serial domestic abuser who's also
also exposed himself to children
we know that part of it the left has no
problem with that whatsoever
um and they really don't have a problem
with the domestic violence either
especially when it comes to these blm
martyrs
it it is it is really incredible how
consistent this is
you know i always point this out and i
can i'm continually pointing it out
because it keeps happening
these blm martyrs and john thompson
tried to be
he wants to be one of them tried to
martyr himself
um almost always it turns out that these
are
violent abusers of women and yet again
it's the same thing here
and no big surprise actually because
here's john thompson
before he was elected this was back in
2020
before he was elected standing outside
of a white family's house where kids are
present
screaming at them for having a blue
lives matter sign in their yard
let's listen to that i'm a black man
he is terrorized by this right here
we are terrorized by the grand wisdom
y'all got the grand wizard living in
your
neighborhood on the clan existed hugo
minnesota and it's right here
don't run now don't run now racist white
people i'm here oh yeah we pull up
yeah he's being terrorized by that the
family those women it's all women out
there
including kids
he's terrorized by them because of what
a sign they have in the yard
and after that incident which which uh
went viral at least locally
he was elected and not in spite of that
these voters elected him because of that
they want these
these scumbag pieces of garbage
representing them that's what they want
and they get exactly this is what you
get when you when you elect people like
this
this is exactly what you get voters in
his district you absolute
morons you're you are
bad people also for electing someone
like that
that is that is a moral failing to elect
someone like that
you elected because you like the way he
screamed at white people
what other what other qualifications did
he bring to the table he's not even a
resident of your district
he doesn't even live with you
but he really liked how he uh you know
how he he showed those white girls
what's what
this is not we got to stop acting like
voters are
you know innocent helpless victims you
you went to the polls and voted for this
guy
not much better than him
just this guy's a liar a fraud an abuser
a
horrible scumbag garbage person
and uh yeah you know elect him to
represent you well he represents you
you want him to represent you and so he
does he's garbage
i don't know if the shoe fits you wanted
him representing you
all right moving on npr has um
exposed the daily wire this is quite the
uh
quite the expose so apparently the daily
wire
of which uh i i i made shocking to learn
i am uh employed
by the daily wire uh so we do pretty
well on facebook
and that's that's a problem that's a
that's a big issue that people
people on facebook like to engage with
our content
that's a big problem and so the npr has
this article
uh expose written by miles parks
and the headline is outrage as a
business model how ben
shapiro is using facebook to build an
empire
of course we talk about all the irony of
the media the mainstream left-wing media
claiming
that we're using outrage as a business
model
i mean they they spent the last why is
it
that the ratings in the mainstream media
and the audience is taking a nosedive
right now
because their whole business model for
the last five years has been nothing but
outrage over donald trump and now he's
not in the scene anymore
and they got nothing else to talk about
they have to find some other target for
their outrage
and their target in this case is us
ironically as they accuse us of doing
the exact same thing this is the same
media
that sent a lynch mob after some after
some
some some kids in dc because they were
smiling at a native american man
they made that into a national story
and they're worried about outrage being
used as a business model okay
but here's what miles parks has to say
uh the conservative podcast hosts ben
shapiro an author's personal facebook
page has more followers in the
washington post
and he drives an engagement machine
unparalleled by anything else on the
world's biggest social networking site
an npr analysis of social media data
found that over the past year
stories published by the site shapiro
founded the daily wire received more
like shares and comments on facebook
than any other news publisher by a wide
margin even legacy news organizations
have broken major stories or produce
groundbreaking investigative work
but don't come anywhere close well
sucks for them what can i say daily wire
articles with headlines such as book
review
proof that wokeness's projection by
nervous racist white women
who can't talk to minorities without
elaborate codes regularly garner tens of
thousands of shares for the site
and shapiro is turning that facebook
reach into a rapidly expanding
cost-efficient media empire one that
experts worry
may be further furthering polarization
in the united states
well if the experts are worried then
what can you say
it continues the daily wire has turned
anger into an art form
and recycled content into a business
model
in may the daily wire generated more
facebook engagement on its articles than
the new york times the washington post
nbc news and cnn combined
this all this is blatantly is jealousy
they are
jealous of the traffic we get and that's
that's
all this is these are like the teenage
girls
jealous of of one of the other teenage
girls
and spreading rumors about her that
that's that's all this comes back to
really this is a mean girls thing
um and of course in reality
in reality facebook is doing quite a lot
to throttle our traffic and keep our
engagement down
believe you me facebook is aware of this
problem
that uh people with unapproved opinions
are having
some success you know
uh interacting with people and uh and
engaging with people on their platform
and they're they're they are taking
steps to address it and that's all that
really is what this article is meant to
do
even though as far as i read and
honestly i didn't read the entire thing
um i did skim through to see if my own
name was mentioned
like a narcissist and uh what i'm most
offended by is that it wasn't
i mean i'm spreading hate and outrage
too i don't get a mention
i think that's pretty outrageous but um
as far as i can tell they don't they
don't they stop short of directly
calling for facebook to kick us off of
their platform but that is what they're
calling for
very very thinly veiled what they're
saying to facebook is hey
hint hint nudge nudge this is a problem
you've got these right wingers that are
using your platform and they've got an
audience
maybe someone should do something about
that i don't know wink
that's that's all this comes back to but
what do they actually have a problem
with
i mean let's why is it
that the daily wire is so successful on
facebook
is it a conspiracy is facebook going out
of their way to help us
clearly not that would appear to be the
left-wing media what they're
insinuating is that is that facebook
what has a right-wing
bias is trying to help us try to help
ben shapiro in the daily wire
no um we do well on facebook
in spite of facebook's you know
algorithm and and the things that
they've done the policy to put in place
in spite of that simply because and i'll
tell you what it is
people like the content if you can
believe it
people enjoy the content we're putting
out there
it speaks to them and so they engage
with it
that's our secret sauce i don't want to
give away the whole
business model but that that really is
it
people like it um and uh
and they engage with it
and that is the media's real problem
i hate to tell you it's not it's it's
not us it's you that they have a problem
with
they don't think that you should like
this kind of content you should not
agree with these kinds of opinions
you should agree with them and if they
can't convince you
then instead what they want to do is
knock out all the competitors
so that their opinions are the only ones
available and you have no choice but to
engage
with their opinions and and to be
exposed to their opinions and maybe if
you're exposed to it for long enough
you'll you'll be beaten down into
submission and start agreeing with them
that
ultimately is the plan uh
and that's why we uh we want
more people we want more people so we
can spread our outrage and our in our
hatred even more
so you can get a daily wire you could
become a daily wire subscriber today
using coupon code umad umad
and you can get 25 off and that way if
the facebook does take the hint here and
try to shut us down
if you're a daily wire subscriber then
you don't have to worry about you don't
have to use
facebook as the gatekeeper to access us
so we would
certainly suggest doing that all right i
got to leave time for this because we
have to move on to our
reading the youtube comments i'm very
excited about what we have in store
um kind of a special edition
of reading you could youtube comments
today um
it this is something that was brought to
my attention
um it's a video from youtube user
sloopy107
that's sloopy107 as a youtube user who
has written
what i think is the sweet baby gang
anthem
she was inspired by the sweet baby gang
to break out into song
we'll play a short clip of it but make
sure to go to her channel you could see
the entire thing it's certainly worth
worth
watching the entire thing um and i
wanted to experience this for the first
time
with all of you my sweet babies so i
haven't listened to very much of it
but here it is let's let's all listen
and together bless america from sea
to shining sea we're denouncing
propaganda
with a sweet baby gang with a true sleep
bear
with the sweet baby gang ask why if you
dare
we get our five headlines and our daily
cancellation
with reality and brevity we get the news
of the nation
speaking truth while searching for those
aliens above
well sweet baby gang god bless america
from sea to shining sea we're denouncing
propaganda
with a sweet baby gang with a true slave
bear
with a sweet baby gang ask why if you
dare discernment perspective evidence
and reason
cringey tic-tacs and psyches malfeasance
the sweet baby gang has no quarter for
commies
as far as we're concerned you can run
home to your mommies
it's beautiful is it really a tear
coming to my eye
that i think is and i don't want to
overstate it
and it's not just because it's about me
but i think you can make an argument
that that is the greatest artistic
achievement
certainly in modern history possibly of
all time
i don't think anyone has ever
picked up a guitar or any musical
instrument
and used their voice to create music
more beautiful more true and more
profound than what you just heard
absolutely uh
stunning performance there's music that
will live on
in my heart for all time so
sloopy 107. i do uh i do not ban you
from the show you are
what's the opposite of band i need
something else i need a pause ignited
canonized whatever it is
i thank you for sharing that beautiful
music with us
as we discussed npr you know is using
hyperbolic
lies to accuse the daily wire of
spreading hyperbolic lies
and hate and outrage and sadness all
across
the land the establishment media tries
so hard to dominate every source of
information and
when they can't they're sore losers mean
girls about it
unfortunately for npr and other legacy
media but fortunately for you we're
hitting them again this time
on podcast daily wire presents morning
wire our daily news podcast that values
your time
and the truth brought to you by daily
wire editor-in-chief john bickley and
co-host georgia howe morningwire
will wake you up with the latest
developments in politics sports culture
and education all with a heavy emphasis
on the facts it's available right now so
subscribe to morning wire on apple
podcast spotify
and everywhere you listen to podcasts
you don't miss a beat
and also while the white house attempts
to censor anything they deem
misinformation
is uh and this is extraordinarily
upsetting it actually accurately depicts
all of the themes in ben shapiro's new
book
the authoritarian moment which hits
bookshelves next tuesday july 27th so
it's almost here and it will be a huge
event
because ben will be doing a live stream
book signing next tuesday
so you can pre-order your signed copy
now at dailywire.com ben
when you do you'll be asked to type in a
question at checkout and then maybe
he'll answer that question and you'll
certainly get your signed copy so get
your copy at dailywire.com
ben right now so you don't miss out now
let's get to our daily cancellation
so it seems almost cheap to play this
video for
a daily cancellation because these are
these things are a dime a dozen but the
fact that they're a dime a dozen
is precisely the point i'm not sure when
this was originally filmed seems to be
recent but it went viral yesterday this
is conservative commentator
caitlin bennett doing one of those
trusty always fruitful dumb guy on the
street interviews
again you've seen these a million times
and that's the problem
but this one is perhaps even worse than
you might expect
just listen what year did america
declare its independence
girl july 1st 1989
what year did christopher columbus
discover the americans love christopher
don't know i mean i'm done christopher
was it 1976 how many years make up a
century
isn't it a thousand what year was george
w bush elected president
oh the 1800s i'm assuming
i don't know who was the last president
of the 1990s
1990s oh
uh i actually have no idea nixon what
year was barack obama
elected president i don't even know what
century are we currently living in
let's just go 50th i don't
america was discovered in 1976 and
declared independence on july 1
1989. it seems like a pretty quick
timeline but then again we are living in
the 50th century so all that stuff
happened while like 3000 years ago
um this is needless to say some
extremely dumb stuff you have to try to
be this dumb
it must be exhausting to be so
overwhelmingly moronic on a daily basis
every hour of the day can you imagine if
i had to carry this level of stupidity
around with me all the time
i'd collapse and have a heart attack the
coroner would say yep looks like he had
a fatal case of the dumbs
third one this week it's an epidemic now
all of the uh the necessary qualifiers
must be added that these were the
dumbest of the dumb
who made it into the clip presumably
plenty of people answered the question
easily and were summarily cut from the
final edit
but even so it is way too easy to go out
and get content like this
uh we know that these kinds of videos
are the tip of the idiot iceberg
there's been a great many surveys and
polls with larger sample sizes that have
come to similar conclusions
think of that c-span poll a few years
ago that found half of americans
can't name one sitting supreme court
justice
there was a survey in 2019 that found 20
of americans
can't correctly identify a single branch
of government
the poll in 2017 showed that almost 40
percent can't cite
any of the rights protected in the first
amendments
the woodrow wilson national fellowship
foundation gave a basic history exam to
41 000 american adults
a year or two ago and found that 60
percent couldn't pass it
another survey found that almost 40
percent of americans think that benjamin
franklin invented the light bulb
12 thought eisenhower was a civil war
general
a civil war general eisenhower um
i could go on and on and on the point is
that stupidity
is a national crisis i believe that it
is
and what makes it worse is that there is
no mitigating circumstance
to let the stupid people off the hook no
adult with a brain
capable of basic functioning has any
cover here
none of them have an excuse because
everyone has access to the accumulated
knowledge of all mankind
right at their fingertips everyone can
find any information they want
and accessing it as is as easy as moving
their thumbs across a screen
it's not like it was in say 1890 when
huge swaths of the population were never
taught how to read
and their only source of information
about the outside world and current
events was maybe at best a weekly
newspaper
that a lot of them couldn't read and
then whatever scuttlebutt you heard
around town
if you were within a day's travel of any
kind of town
if they wanted to know to know something
if there was information that they
didn't have that they wanted
there was obviously no search engine
which with which to find it
although i would like to interview those
same people and ask them when do you
think
google was invented i don't know
1573
but if someone back in those days you
know they couldn't use a search engine
engine if they wanted to know something
they could ask someone
or they could try to find the
information in whatever books were
accessible
and if the information wasn't there if
nobody around them knew it
and it wasn't in a book then they just
just weren't ever going to know that
thing
they would have to say well i guess i'm
not going to know that
there were so many things about the
world that a person in those days
may have wanted to know but simply could
not know
because there was no way to acquire the
knowledge
compare that today to today when if if i
want to know
for instance how many earths can fit in
the sun
1.3 million or how old the the oldest
living vertebrate
500 year old greenland shark is or or
whether the pain in my back is a sign
that i'm dying of a rare bone disease
yes
i could just look it up on the internet
and have the answer in the blink of an
eye
and yet with this tool with this vast
expanse of knowledge
readily available still we choose
dumbness
it's like a guy in the desert collapsing
and dying of thirst
while wearing a camelback full of water
it doesn't make any it's
it almost doesn't make any sense so how
does this happen
how do we end up snatching in facility
from the jaws of knowledge
well part of the blame goes to the
school system which has utterly failed
to do the one thing it is supposed to do
in which we're paying good money for it
to do
part of the blame goes to the media
which muddies the water with lies and
half truths
part of the blame goes to the internet
itself which offers knowledge but also
offers cheap and constant distraction
it gives you the choice to feed your
mind or numb it
expand your horizons or lose yourself
in the fog most people it turns out
prefer the numb and the fog because it's
easy
and it keeps you from thinking about
uncomfortable things like your own
mortality
which i believe is the primary motivator
that drives our screen addiction in the
first place
is that we don't want to think about
immortality but but notice the word
choice
the one thing about modern society for
all of its flaws
is that it offers a lot of choices
more choices than anyone in history ever
had
too many choices it turns out but they
are choices all the same
whether you use the internet to make
yourself smarter and more interesting
which you can do
or dumber and duller is a choice
and that's why after partial blame has
been doled out this way and that
the rest the majority must fall on the
ignoramuses
themselves whose obliviousness and
foolishness is as much a moral failing
as an intellectual one
and that's why and you knew this was
coming back around
because it always does everyone in that
video and all the videos like it
should not be allowed to vote it is a we
make a mockery of ourselves by allowing
all of those people to vote
and it's also why and you definitely
knew this was coming
they're all canceled
well let's not focus on all those
negative things let us let us
let us focus on the song the sweet baby
song that is now
in all of our hearts as we go about our
day
and we'll leave it there for today we're
going to let sweet baby play us out we
are
have a great day everyone godspeed we're
the sweet baby gang
and god bless america
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021.
inflation spikes media credibility
craters
and rural democrats ditch their party
affiliation
check it out on the michael knowles show